call me dude Z are you healing up from
your Mexican scooter accident it wasn't
a Mexican scooter accident it was a
scooter accident in Mexico you [__]
racist my body's still in a lot of pain
thank you for asking yeah my pleasure
dude my pain is your pleasure dude hold
on dude pain is pleasure dude when
you're when you're in the gym dude and
you're clanging and banging
hold on will don't talk during the song
brother
dude do you know bwp here we go problems
no one can hear him do you know that
um
[Music]
I'm not talking to you right now
and now I have to do now I have to do
the show
so do I uh hey I didn't say you didn't
oh we're off to a horrible start welcome
to doozy I'm Will Sasso
I can't laugh